we have had a great great relationship
and i'm really happy
and not everything has to end badly
bethenny frankel getting candid about
her recent split from her boyfriend of
two years
paul vernon some things just don't
continue
and it's not negative it's just life the
49 year old businesswoman appeared on
the ellen degeneres show
friday and said she's moving forward
with nothing but love
i know that you just went through a
breakup so before
we go on are you okay how are you i'm
good
uh you know not everything
works out and so many people have tried
to define
my life with you know our lives with
when are you getting engaged when are
you having a baby when are you getting
married and i've just realized more
in life with people being more open and
honest about their lives and what they
want that
everything doesn't have to sort of end
in a blue box and a bow
the two started dating in october 2018
following the death of her on-again
off-again boyfriend dennis shields
that august when et spoke to bethany in
march
she said that ironically the covet 19
pandemic brought them closer than
ever despite the reality star being in
new york city with her 10 year old
daughter brynn
and paul quarantining in boston you
closer to the people that you
can't be with you're feeling like you
want to talk to them and facetime them
and you miss them
and so we are closer than ever but i
want to go there i just we're both sort
of panicked if i go and i can't leave
and
it's not rational because i'm sure i'd
be able to leave but i just
you know you want to just feel in your
safe place at the moment and while they
may have called it quits
bethany says there's no bad blood some
things just
don't continue and it's not negative
it's just
life so would newly single bethany ever
consider returning to the real
housewives of new york city
i have been on reality television i have
been part of that machine
she says don't hold your breath being
respectful to where i came from
i'm in a different place now and i think
that the opportunities that i'm i'm
getting and some of these interviews for
example
might not have happened if i was still
on that show and the former real
housewives star says that
since leaving the show in 2019 she's
been able to focus more on the things
she cares about
most when you jump you fly i left a big
financial
paycheck there but i knew that something
amazing was going to happen and that the
journey was just going to take me in a
great place
and so i believe in the path and this is
where i am and i've been so focused on
the things that i'm doing
whether it's relief work or my daughter
or the podcast that i'm excited about
what's happening now
the rocket is flying and um you know i'm
ready i gotta stay on
you know i'm just taking everything day
by day but really it's good now
really good